Keeney [ __ ] you're so hot right now
but no like this is Keeley Hawes time
it's well hey well I mean yeah I don't
really know what to say you know I know
it's a weird thing with none of those
things happen when you're 43 that's a
bit weird
yeah and you've been in this you know
business for 200 years and suddenly your
heart it's um no it's an interesting one
but body guard took off in a way that I
think no one expected it was completely
insane and people are always saying to
me what what was it you know that create
what's the recipe for that sort of
success well if I knew I saw it all it's
incredibly good I mean I made up way too
late just to say I haven't I haven't
seen it yet so can you not talk about it
you won't believe what you just don't
talk about it
it's all in America now yes is that what
you do you see it in America yes yeah
you see a bill no I haven't I'm like mad
I don't want to hear a lot about it yeah
people are watching in America as she's
really dead
doesn't come back he doesn't come back
you think she was going to come back
alive whoa wait a minute
that's how complete red herring that
doesn't exist
what he just said no no no they're gonna
get really confused now Sally she's dead
I dunno if you had this problem but
apparently American viewers have some
confusion over Richard Madden's
character and his relationship with you
yes because of his fabulous Scottish
accent and whenever he calls me Mom cuz
I'm his boss he said he actually calls
me mum yes I did notice that
that's a big plot twist no one's talking
about someone I do know who did this but
someone's got a compilation of him
saying mom mom mom no yes mom thanks mom
[Applause]
he did say to me you know we've done a
few scenes and lots of dialogue has
playing the Home Secretary lots of chat
and and occasionally he would reply with
yes moment and he said I think I say mom
had bit too much no 23 times in episode
1 but no I love the way he says mom okay
moving on she's dead
[Applause]
[Music]
you